- I love hearing my name.
I love my name.
I don't care if that's vain,
'cause I spent a lot
of time hating my name.
- [Narrator] Our names
are powerful, literally.
Our brains have a unique reaction
to the sound of our names,
sometimes even while sedated,
but many students have their names
mispronounced or disregarded
every day in school.
So what impact does that
have on their education?
And what can educators do?
- [Woman] My name is Adenis.
- Ajani.
- Jamara.
- Javia.
- Nekbakht.
- Alilia.
- Nadesh Visimungu.
- Raghdan.
- It's actually Nichbacht, not
Nichbat, Nichbich, Nichbod.
(bright music)
- [Lilia] Two of the embarrassing
the moment when there's a pause
and you know it's 'cause of you.
- [Raghdan] It just goes so far
that sometimes it's even concerning.
Like, Rajakada.
- [Amara] I remember just
being like, "Oh, that must be."
- Especially if they said David.
Everyone would laugh.
- [Ajani] I learned pretty quickly
that it was easier to just go by AJ,
which is something that I, quite honestly,
regret doing now.
- [Narrator] In 2012,
researchers Doctor Rita Kohli
and Doctor Daniel Solorrzzano
published a study called,
"Teachers, please learn our names!:
racial mioxcroaggressions
and the K-12 classroom."
Here's Doctor Kohli.
- [Doctor Kohli] Schools are
not a power-neutral space.
Teachers are an authority figure.
Teachers how power in those contexts.
And so, often, what they say goes.
Often, what they say is viewed as
the legitimate knowledge in the space.
- [Narrator] So it takes a lot
for a first grader to
say to their teacher,
"Excuse me, you pronounced
my name this way,
"but it's actually this way
"and it matters to me."
In fact, it takes a lot
for a student of any age.
- The first time I ever
tried to confront a professor
was actually last semester,
and it wasn't really a good experience.
- Some professors
just don't even ask.
They're just like, "Can
I call you by this name?"
- She mispronounced my name
then asked me if she can
call me something else.
- Regardless of whether we want
to be called a certain way or not,
it's an elder person
who has a PhD, and this, and that.
- Later on, I felt like
it was my responsibility
to actually email and tell her that,
"Professor, I get that it's
the first day of class,
"but you don't even have the right
"to ask me if you can
call me "something else."
She later on apologized,
but it's only because we pushed
the conversation forward.
- [Narrator] So, what is the big deal?
- If you can't understand my name
how can you understand me?
- [Narrator] A microaggression
is a subtle form
of discrimination that can occur
intentionally or unintentionally,
and it can include telling a student
their name is too hard to say.
- We're centering a particular
cultural vantage point
when we say things are
difficult to pronounce,
because they're not really
difficult to pronounce inherently.
They're difficult to pronounce for us.
- [Narrator] Doctor Kohli's
research underscores
that a person's name is their
entrance point to the world.
So, what happens when those
names are mispronounced,
disregarded, or even mocked?
- [Doctor Kohli] They start to feel
like their name was a burden,
they start to feel like they
themselves were a burden,
and so they begin to withdraw sometimes
from participating socially
and academically in schools.
- [Narrator] There's actually a term
for the unintended lessons
kids learn in school.
Things that live between
the lines, and in hallways,
and in roll call.
- [Al-Jawhara] There's
a lot that we impart
onto our students or onto each other
that is complete subtext.
We don't say it out loud.
- [Narrator] Al-Jawhara Al-Thani
is the head of educational
and community programs
at Qatar Foundation.
Her work focuses on hidden curriculum
and how to fix it.
- [Al-Jawhara] I was in a class once,
a sixth grade all boys English class,
and it was like like 15
minutes quiet reading time.
I was sitting at the back of the class.
At one point, the boy puts his hand up
and asks the teacher, he's like,
"Sir, I have a question."
He goes, "Yeah?"
He goes, "Why are they all white?"
You think kids don't register?
It registers.
- [Narrator] There are
decades worth of studies
examining how curriculum,
sometimes the world over,
is primarily Euro-centric,
male, and upper class
with names to match.
It registers.
But, the curriculum is
not always something
that's up to a teacher themselves.
Learning names, on the other hand, is.
- You're sitting in the
back row in a lecture
of 200 students meeting on your phone.
You're gonna get me calling you by name,
"What are you doing?"
- [Narrator] Professor
Susan Dun has been teaching
at Northwestern University
in Qatar for over a decade.
Her undergrad experience
at a liberal arts college
with small classes influenced her decision
to memorize the names of
every student in her classes,
wherever she teaches.
Even in the 200-person lectures.
- [Susan] For me, teaching
is about a lot more
than just transmission of knowledge.
It's about the growth and development
of human beings,
and so I can be far more
effective in doing that
if I have at least a recognition of
know the identity of
people, know their names,
know a little bit of something about them.
Even in a large class.
That they know when they
walk in and I say, "Hi,"
and use their name, that I
really know who they are.
- When I hear someone
say my name correctly,
I'd be like, "Oh my god.
"Finally this person!
"They know how to say my name!"
- I think in our
increasingly globalized world
where we have people from all sorts of
walks of life interacting,
that the idea that
we're gonna mispronounce
each other's names is pretty much a given.
And so the question and the challenge is
to do as much as we can to figure out
how to embrace each other,
which sometimes starts with simply
taking the time and effort to figure out
how to greet each other properly.
- Why we're not asking teachers
to be able to say
everybody's name correctly
the second they walk through the door,
but I think there's a difference between
imposing that, "Oh, your
name is hard to say,"
versus, "I haven't learned how
to say a name like this yet,
"but I'm working on it
because you're important,
"and your name is important,
and I want to honor that
"in my classroom."
- [Narrator] What working
on it looks like in practice
might be different for every educator.
What's key is allowing teachers the room
to be students in this too.
- If we flip this around
and we think about the
expectation for students
to learn lots of new things
all at the same time,
and we encourage them to fail,
and we encourage them to keep trying,
and we encourage them,
I think that vulnerability
that we expect of students
should be the same expectation
that we have of our teachers.
They aren't the holders of all knowledge.
We know that.
We know that they're human.
- [Davia] What would I
tell my younger self?
I would tell her to be proud
that you have a unique name.
- [Raghdan] The fact that
you have such a unique name
doesn't make you stand
out in a negative way,
but instead it makes you shine.
- Know that's like snithing, embarrassing.
- It's gonna take time,
but you will understand
how important your name is actually,
and how your parents did not name you
just for the sake of naming someone.
- I would tell my younger self
to learn about the
significance of your name
and call that teacher out when
they mispronounce your name.
- I would probably just
take my younger self by the shoulders,
look him dead in the eye, and
tell him, "Your name means
"He who wins the struggle, and it'll be
a prophesy if you let it be."